le laisser vraiment prendre sa décision
elle-même mais elle sait qu'elle est pas
obligé de partir
depuis près d'un an Isabelle et son mari
ont accueilli gracieusement Nathalie et
ses deux fillettes qui ont fui la guerre
en Ukraine laissant Marie et famille
derrière elle je vous repartir parce que
je ne veux pas habiter ici seul avec mes
enfants
mon ami mon mari me manquer
après avoir été intégré dans la vie de
cette famille québécoise depuis près
d'un an la décision est prise elle
repartent dans quelques jours c'est
l'heure de dire merci Isabelle Sébastien
ce sont des très fantastique je suis
très insalée ma reconnaissance
ça sert un peu on a été habitué moi je
l'ai accueilli dans le fond en lui
disant qu'elle était comme ma sœur que
ses fils étaient comme mes nièces
d'accepter que qu'il y a toujours un
doute il y a toujours des
c'est la guerre fait que c'est sûr qu'on
sait pas qu'est-ce qui va se passer
comment c'était chez Isabelle
Angelina 8 ans exprime avec clarté les
émotions que suscite ce départ je me
sens un peu trop
d'ici mais je me sens un peu triste de
de de
vous savez j'aimerais mieux être dans
dans un puis dans l'autre parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses que j'aime ici puis
beaucoup de choses que j'aime le crâne
puis que je parle 31 mai puis le 30
c'est ma dernière journée à l'école
tu sais dans la dernière année sont là
pour rester les deux familles
demeureront en contact malgré la
distance je vais envoyer des biscuits
des recettes oui comme le cœur va finir
peut-être
on va retourner au Canada peut-être avec
mon mari on les laisse en leur disant
que s'ils veulent revenir la porte est
ouverte aussi le mot de la fin revient à
la petite Antonina qui n'a qu'un seul
buttière Radio-Canada
saint-augustin-des-maures